[Music]
hi my name is code li and i'm rossik and
we're both engineers on the Android auto
team here to talk to you about what's
new for app developers and Android auto
now we're a credibly excited at Google
about the automotive space right now
because we see going through a huge
transformation in connectivity
electrification interfaces and sensors
sharing an autonomy cars are rapidly
turning into full-blown computers on
wheels
they've got high-speed mobile
connections cameras microphones and
screens of all shapes and sizes
everywhere Android auto is an effort
from Google and our automotive partners
to bring these advances together and
create a safe and seamless connected
experience for drivers everywhere of
course that's easier said than done
there are dozens of different car
platforms today many different input
types from touchscreens to touch pads to
rotary controllers many different screen
shapes sizes and resolutions today you
can see that vision at work in any
Android auto compatible car drivers have
access to their favorite apps right from
their cars display and developers build
their app once without worrying about
different makes and models input
controls and screens today we'll talk
about two of the most important app
categories messaging and media it's
great so first up is messaging messaging
has come a long way in both Android auto
and Android the OS when Android auto
started supporting messaging there
wasn't really a good way for messaging
apps to get their messaging information
over to the car that's where car
extender came into play car extender
allowed a way for messaging apps to
provide conversation details and a way
to reply to conversations to Android
auto but since Android n apps could
stylize their notifications with
something called messaging style
messaging style is a huge step up from
car extender as it allows messaging apps
to provide conversation information
directly into the notification
not only does it provide a nicer UI for
conversation details but it provides
affordances like replying and liking
directly in line to the notification
Android auto now fully supports the use
of messaging style and actions without
the need for car extender
this also means Android auto and the
assistant both fully support group
messaging so for the price of
implementing messaging style apps not
only gain a richer mobile user
experience but also gain the benefit of
automotive support so let's see how
Android auto interfaces with these with
this starting on the messaging app side
from Android autos point of view
messaging apps have three core functions
notifying users of messages marking
those messages as read and replying to
those messages working backwards apps
can implement reading and replying with
services these services can be triggered
internally with intense or externally
like via Android auto with pending
intents notifying is done via an Android
notification and the messaging
information is provided with the
messaging style the mark is read and
reply pending intents are wrapped in
actions and both provided in the
notification as well note here that the
reply action has a remote input that's
added that acts as a sort of input field
for the reply and that's the messaging
apps architecture moving on to the other
side of the notification we can see how
Android auto leverages these objects
Android auto will first post an in-car
notification and once tapped on will
read aloud the messages contained within
the mark as read pending intent is then
fired the user is given the choice to
respond and have taken a transcription
of that response is set in that remote
input the reply pending intent is then
fired and that's the entire Android auto
flow so let's see how we can put that
into code first the app needs to declare
support for Android auto to do that it
needs to create a new XML file that's
linked in the Android manifest
this XML file says that it has
notifications that Android auto should
take a look at note that for messaging
apps that support SMS MMS or RCS this
uses SMS bit also needs to be added so
now Android auto is taking a look at our
messages we can build up the messaging
style so we can't really have a
conversation without people so the first
person we have to add is the user of the
device to do that we create this new
person object person is used to set
things like the user's name their icon
and a unique key in the event that
multiple people have the same name so we
create this device user and we create
the messaging style with it we can then
add our conversation information so I'm
from Seattle and I love skiing so I'm
setting the conversation title to ski
group because this I'm taking multiple
friends this is a group conversation so
the messaging app needs to set it as
such
note here that conversation title and
whether or not the conversation is a
group can be set independently this is
new in Android P and has been back
ported to older Android versions in the
compat library and finally we can add
all the messages in this conversation in
the order they were received in this
case my friend wants to coordinate
breakfast so the messaging app provides
the text the timestamp and the sender in
the form of a person with this
conversation setup it's time to add the
actions for the reply action we
instantiate an action builder and set
the semantic action to semantic action
reply that must also tell the OS that
firing the reply pending intent won't
show any extra UI this is especially
important in Android auto because we
don't want to be distracting drivers
with extra pop-ups finally the reply
action is supplied with that remote
input I talked about earlier on the mark
is read side things are done about the
same way this time the semantic action
is set to semantic action mark is read
and again we tell the OS that firing
that pending intent won't show extra UI
note here that the Marcus red action
does not need a remote input so that's
all three pieces the notification can
now be built for reference here are the
three elements we created messaging
style which holds all our conversation
information our reply action and our
Marcus red action to build a
notification some boilerplate is
provided and then we set the messaging
style we can then add our actions here
is where the messaging app has some
options
note that the reply action is added as a
regular visible action and the Marcus
red action is added as invisible this is
purely stylistic one can add both
actions as visible or invisible this
will just change how it shows up in the
mobile UI on Android auto actions are
never shown but Android auto will be
able to read both visible and invisible
actions and finally the messaging app
can post the notification and there we
have it my friends and I have planned
breakfast on the road and our ski trip
is under way and now that we've
coordinated with everybody let's find
something to listen to you on the drive
out to the mountains media in the car is
one of our core user experiences and
getting drivers access to their content
should be front and center I'm going to
talk about several new features we're
introducing today to enhance the
abilities of media apps provide content
within Android auto in particular we
want to make content more visually
pleasing by adding additional content
style hints and enabling additional
search results provided by the app to
start off let's go over the architecture
that app has when communicating with
Android auto the first thing in media
app needs is a Media Browser service it
provides a tree of playable and
browsable items browsable items are
basically folders to organize app
content instead of returning a giant
list of playable items the media apps
implement the onload children method
which loads a particular level of the
tree here in our first call to onload
children our example service would
return home recently played recommend
and playlists now since this is running
in a car
we recommend that media apps only
provide two levels in the tree to avoid
distracting drivers and making them
click through multiple levels while
they're driving
now once the users pick something
playable from the Browse tree the media
session service is used to start playing
music and to provide metadata and
controls to show what's currently
playing for example our media app that
we're showing here supports play pause
skip forward and skip back and we show
that in the Android auto UI there's also
the ability for media apps to provide
their own custom actions may be
something like 30-second skip obviously
we want to get the user away from
touching or doing things while they're
driving so we bring in the assistance
might say something like a google play
my ski gems the Google assistant
performs speech recognition and can
request that the media session service
play the query and music starts playing
we're gonna take it one step farther
today we're given the ability for media
apps to implement an additional function
on the Media Browser service on search
and once the music has started playing
from a Google assistant query we'll
provide that query to the media app and
they can provide additional results here
in this case the media provided a ski
trip playlist from this year as well as
one from last year so let's take a look
at the code needed to make this happen
perhaps already support Android auto
this should look pretty familiar this is
the on search method it takes the query
string an extras bundle and a result
object which the app fills in and sends
back to Android auto first off apps
should return an empty list if they get
a query they don't support second for
queries that can't be answered
synchronously apps detach from results
object and that lets the media framework
know that not to wait and not to send
anything back to Android auto right away
this gives a chance for apps to do extra
work on a background thread before
sending the results to Android auto
and finally when the results are ready
they can send the results and the result
object and Android auto will be notified
and show the results on screen now all
these code snippets come from the
universal music player an open source
media app published by Google on github
it can be easily cloned compiled and
used as a great reference building your
own media app so voila our ldia returns
the list of items from the ski jams
query notice it returned to playlists in
an album it'd be really nice if Android
auto could group those items and show
them to the user as a groups fortunately
we're introducing a way to do that in
the on search results here's an example
function which your media app might use
to convert from an internal
representation of a media item into the
Media Browser compact
media item that Android auto needs we
can annotate items with a category extra
and Android auto will group any adjacent
items with the same category and show a
heading for the two ski trip playlist we
can annotate with playlists and Android
Auto will group them together and add
the heading for you we're also adding
some additional annotations on media
items that would be really useful on our
trip for example I may be heading out to
the mountains with my family I worry
that maybe a song comes on that has some
explicit content we now add the ability
to say ok this particular playlist or
song has explicit content and Android
Auto can show that in the UI similarly
out in the mountains I might not have
great bandwidth I'd love to know if the
playlists or songs have already been
downloaded or maybe I don't want to burn
my data on music that I'm playing we can
also annotate with it whether or not
media items have been downloaded and are
already on the device great
looks like the ski trip 2018 it's
already downloaded doesn't have any
explicit contest content great choice
for my trip out to the mountains there's
one more function that needs updating
the Media Browser service on get route
is called when a media app is first
connected to by Android auto
in order for search and for the
additional styling hints to be enabled
you'll need to add a couple of extras to
let Android auto know that you support
those features as I mentioned we're
introducing the concept of additional
content styling and Android Auto will be
in for interpreting the Browse tree
returned by apps in a much more visually
pleasing way by default items which are
browsable like folders will be
interpreted as lists this is how we do
things today but for playable items
things like songs or albums or playlists
we're gonna be showing them now as grids
most of these items have much richer
visual content that users can identify
by seeing much easier than reading and
much safer when you're in the car there
are however times when a list is better
than a grid for example in a podcast app
each of the individual podcasts would
probably have individual art that is
much more visually representative while
the episodes instead they don't have all
the same art but different episode
titles and lengths and in Statten status
and it'd be much better to show them as
lists in the on get route function we
can the media app can provide a hint to
Android auto to say I prefer my browse
of items to be grids and my playable
items to be lists or vice-versa so they
have full control over how we're showing
the items I already mentioned the
universal media player I just want to
reiterate it's a great comprehensive
sample media app that's available it
gives you a canonical implementation of
a media app that actually plays music
and it also supports it's worth Android
auto as well as other surfaces like
where an Android TV and if you are
developing a media app I also encourage
you to check out the Android media
controller another open source app
hosted on github it'll connect to your
apps a media session and Media Browser
service and it shows you information
that your app is presenting to Android
auto and a clear semantic format if
you're using whitelisting to block apps
other than Android auto from accessing
your browse tree it probably a good idea
to either add the media controller to
the whitelist or do
stable the whitelist while testing so to
sum up we've shown code samples for
messaging style notification actions
providing search results with the Media
Browser service comp ad on search
attaching new extras for media items
metadata and declaring support for
content browse and search in route hints
so great we look forward to seeing all
of your messaging and media apps in the
car Rasika and I will be available
tomorrow morning at office hours to
answer any questions you have about
Android auto thank you all for watching
[Music]